let's begin with breaking news coming
out of Bangladesh where a fire has
broken out at a rohingya refugee camp in
Cox's Bazaar emergency services are at
the scene volunteers are also assisting
in efforts to douse the Flames these are
pictures coming from the area now fires
are a regular Occurrence at these camps
at the border with Myanmar some of the
largest refugee camps in the world let's
uh join Tunbridge Audrey our
correspondent in Bangladesh she joins me
on the phone from the capital Dhaka and
tanvir let's just talk about these camps
there are several camps in the Cox's
Bazaar area so which Camp has this fire
occurred at and how quickly are your
contacts telling you that emergency
services were able to try and start
working on dousing the flames
well this trap is known as balukali Camp
there's 32 camps and balukali is one of
them it's they're nearly about 1.2
million it's the largest refugee camp in
the world so that's a population of some
major cities in the world living in
barely 34 square kilometer area very
densely packed and so for the latest I
know from the camp when I talked to our
contacts is that the fire is still on
they don't know the reason it started
but it could be one of those cooking
cylinder guests they use most of the
families get one cylinder for cooking
and most cases those are the culpis
that's where the fire usually they're
due to explosion or the fire started
because most of these Huts are made out
of bamboos and tarpaulin and the fire
ignite very quickly and because that
split pack the fire spread very quickly
the last incident we know of was on
March 221 and daily nearly dozen people
died 50 000 have Scott Burns and many
others got injured and that's one of the
many incidents that happened we're
seeing the cases sorry yeah we're seeing
the latest pictures at the moment tanvir
we're also seeing the location of the
The Blaze itself this location is quite
hilly uh and it would be difficult for
emergency services to actually get to
the source of the Flames local obviously
local people are trying to help in
whatever way they can just describe the
location of these these camps and in
what terrain people having to deal with
this emergency
absolutely uh the location is very hilly
you're right this is in the southeast of
Bangladesh which is a hilly region it's
basically a forest area which has been
cleared for the camp so it's very
challenging for our fire trucks to get
into these really tops so they have to
actually manually improvise take the
pipes or they use have some fire
equipment within the camp area after
those incidents but they're very little
for this kind of fire to you know doubt
them so what they use is the sand
buckets and some improvised water types
to help the situation that it hardly
enough to really put the fire under
control it's a very challenging
situation considering most of their
hearts are in the hilltop in a sloppy
Hilltop you can't get the fire trucks
there and there's no you know fire pipes
or anything in those areas a very
rudimentary area and lastly spoke to the
pirates still ongoing there are at least
seven or nine fire trucks trying to help
does the fires and the classroom they
probably will be quite High considering
the fire is spreading as I say it's very
densely packed majority of the
population are women and children so
it's very dangerous situation for the
families because these kids are running
around all around these camps you know
they don't know about all this uh fire
emergency system so it's a very
vulnerable situation indeed densely
packed areas lots of people Roots very
unclear both for the Emergency Services
and for the rohingya refugees that are
there in terms of the emergency Health
Facilities hospitals a e accident units
what sort of infrastructure does
Bangladesh have in that part of the
country because the one thing that the
authorities have always talked about
regarding the refugees they don't get
enough help internationally to service
the the needs of so many in such a small
space
yeah very rightly pointed out it's a
very basic the emergency medical
facilities there are a lot of build
hospitals as NSF hospitals there's a
general hospital which is quite far away
the government General Hospital which is
in Cox's but that town that's literally
one and a half hour drive from there
which does have emergency high-end
facilities but uh still considering 1.2
million people it's very basic very
rudimentary they're just not enough
facilities to have a fox response for
fire victim the way you would expect in
a more developed situation but
considering 2017 and how things have
improved a lot of field Hospital some of
them do have emergency room to trade
this kind of victim but just not enough
for 1.2 million people it's a very
Channel challenging situation in all
circumstances consider the congestion
the hilltop location of this area number
of population it is a very difficult and
challenging environment and just not
enough facilities to deal with this kind
of emergency fires let's talk about the
weather situation at the moment because
obviously fires like this don't erupt
unless the conditions are dry on the
ground what season is this for
Bangladesh obviously parts of the world
are dealing with the winter season but
it seems quite dry at the moment is this
typical for the time of the year because
obviously the drier the scenario the
worse the situation is for those and we
can see rescue workers with hoses at the
moment trying to douse some of the
flames it's incredibly Smoky very dense
and the visibility is quite low so a
difficult time
yes you're right the weather does make a
big difference this is an end of the dry
season it's still not Monsoon Monsoon
won't start till end of April or middle
of May when the rainfall will start so
the trees don't have any leaves it's
very dry there's lots of twigs and dry
leaves on the ground and the weather is
very dry you don't expect any kind of
rain in this season because it is end of
the winter and it's still a very dry
season making it more vulnerable and
this fire could spread because of this
dry weather and as well as dry trees all
around it it used to be barrenberg a lot
of trees around here so it could really
spread very fast in the camp area and
again the Huts are made out of bamboo
which is highly inflammable and the top
is covered with chocolate it's very
basic there's no concrete or any kind of
vegetables like this is a tent or a
circle in with bamboos and the bamboo is
Catch a Fire very quickly in terms of
the the source of the The Blaze that
will have to be invest
but it could have been an accident but
we've also heard that over the last few
weeks and months there's been a little
bit of intercommunal rivalry within
camps themselves is that true and can
you perhaps expand on that for us
um yes uh there at least the rohingya
community themselves say that many of
these fire were actually arson attacks
because there are gang violence within
the camp drug rivalry ganks and there's
also Intergroup rivalry between
different groups and segment within the
camp which has been a major issue in the
camp after his last two years many
people died because of this interview
rivalry at the sum of the Trump leaders
were shot dead even just a couple of
weeks ago at least two running as were
shot dead and this also goes into this
incidence of fire because last time in
the big fire most of the running got
pointed it was an arson which was in
March 2021 the investigate couldn't
conclude exactly the reason behind the
fire because most ringas thinks many of
you fired up started as a field between
different camps and groups and they
usually this arson attacks takes place
but it's difficult to investigate and
pinpoint in that kind of circumstance
considering the environment and
topography you don't have really that
kind of evidence because if I could have
studied in any way you know because of
the cylinders because of dry hoods
around it somebody could lead a fire but
yes this is a major acquisition by the
rohingyas themselves even the government
authorities acknowledge that there's a
very high possibility some of these
fires are Arsen attack just stay with us
on the phone for a moment uh tanveer
while we just bring our viewers up to
speed those of you that are joining us
here on Al Jazeera you're watching live
pictures uh coming from one of the many
uh rohingya refugee camps in the
southeast of the country near Cox's
Bazaar this is most probably the first
Port of Call for many of the rohingya
that have fled uh the persecution that
they've experienced in Myanmar and seek
refuge in Bangladesh the ringer on of
the oldest Refugee groups in the world
and this is if not the largest refugee
camp in the world over 30 smaller camps
in a very large area of Cox's bazaars
you can see the black smoke billowing
from this particular Camp the fire
service is an emergency services have
made it to the scene it's a very
difficult densely packed area The Shack
says tanvir said are made of local
materials wood a bamboo palm trees for
roofing cover so easily ignited in what
is the end of the dry season and heading
into the monsoon season tanvir let's
just talk about the size of these camps
because you say there's over 30 of them
in a very densely packed part of
Southeastern uh Bangladesh when we talk
about the smallest of the camps and the
largest of the camps sort of what sort
of numbers are we talking about when it
comes to those that live in them
go left to the total population now is
at least estimated around 1.2 million
rohingya refugees making it the largest
refugee camp in the world now this
probably holds about tenth of that which
is several hundred thousand and uh it is
about barely 34 square kilometer size
you know so you can imagine that the
population of Washington DC and some big
cities in Europe or America that's
densely packed in a very small area with
very rudimentary facilities making it
extremely challenging environment to
deal with and and talk about that as we
mentioned earlier many of these camps
are located in the hilltop which is
itself is very challenging to go and
Dove the fire with fire trucks because
you won't be able to reach that there's
a ring Rod made by the military to
encircle the camp that is the only
access point where the fire trucks can
go and then they have to use a long
water pipe to go and Dove this fire from
the fire truck that's why it's taking so
long uh to bring it under control and
also there's many other challenging
situations in the campus you mentioned I
mean these are very rudimentary
facilities made with basic bamboos and
the top is covered with chocolate to
protect it from the exposure from rain
and other materials so yeah very
challenging environment and there's just
not have paid and help coming from
overseas after almost six years now the
International Community is more or less
forgot about the rohingya recently
there's been funding which is why the
world food program said that the Russian
for the rohingar which will have a
nutritional effect on the children and
half the population in students so
there's a lot of different direction to
this story not just the fire I mean it's
sacred people who are not considered
this because Bangladesh is not a
signature to the refugee convention
making them essentially the largest
stateless population in the world and no
hope of any repatriation back to Myanmar
because of the political situation there
Insurgency even within the Bangladesh
border area making it more difficult and
challenging there's no negotiations
right now with Myanmar to take them back
making the whole Refugee situation for
the living a very challenging a lot of
diplomatic visit a lot of high-level
visit but nothing tangible really done
by the International Community
Bangladesh has to Bear most of the book
and they've been very generous so far
dealing with the refugees in Bangladesh
and some portion of their activities
have been located to a remote Coastal
Island called passion chart which is my
coast of Bay of Bengal it's in the
middle of
has already been moved and the
government is planning to move all 1.2
million refugees in this island which is
again a very controversial and another
challenging move to say the least well
of course uh we'll leave it there for
now as you get more information from
your sources and we'll join you later on
uh through the day but for those of you
joining us here on Al Jazeera these are
live pictures coming from Southeastern
Bangladesh some of them are the latest
pictures of the blaze that has uh
engulfed the bulac Eli uh Camp uh part
of one of nearly 30 camps in the Cox's
bizarre area that house and host to the
ringa refugees from Myanmar uh as you
can see you know people uh in their
dozens uh leaving the local area thick
black smoke uh covering the whole
vicinity uh quite uncertain I'm sure for
many people which way to go with no real
well-signed posted emergency routes the
Emergency Services finding it very
difficult as you can see to get to the
epicenter of the blaze because the The
Roots into these camps are very narrow
very hilly and just generally just
difficult to get to of course we'll
continue to follow this story uh through
the day and get more information to you
as we get it